et cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous les
gars railleries bonjour bonjour
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
avocate vous êtes l'une des deux
avocates de mohamed amri un mail aux
marocains de 33 ans jugé depuis le mois
de septembre dernier par la cour
d'assises spéciale de paris au procès
dit des attentats du 13 novembre 2015 un
procès qui touche à sa fin après neuf
mois d'audiences historiques tant sur la
forme que sur le fond on va y revenir
d'abord si vous le voulez bien quelques
mots de votre plaidoirie d'hier il ne
s'agit pas évidemment ici de refaire le
fond du dossier ça n'est pas l'endroit
je rappelle simplement à ceux qui nous
regardent que la cour reproche entre
autres choses à votre client d'avoir
ramené salah abdeslam en belgique depuis
paris le soir des attentats l'enjeu pour
vous dans ce procès c'est de défendre un
homme en l'absence des principaux
responsables des faits dont on parle oui
absolument alors ce qu'on lui reproche
c'est en effet de choses vous l'avez
indiqué après les attentats c'était le
fait de ramener salle abdeslam donc le
recel est en amont on lui reprochait
également certaines choses
pas suffisamment caractérisées pour être
une complicité mais suffisamment pour
que ce soit une association de
malfaiteurs terroristes et tout l'enjeu
c'est de demander l'acquittement pour
cette qualification pour laquelle il
encourt 20 ans de réclusion criminelle
et pour laquelle le parquet a requis
huit ans d'emprisonnement vous avez
plaidez-vous l'acquittement hier après
midi les avocats généraux effectivement
requis huit ans de prison le confrère
avec lequel vous défendez mohamed amri a
regretté à l'issue des réquisitions je
le cite que le choix des peines fasse
toujours pensé qu'il y ait un peu de
vindicte là dedans est ce que c'est
votre sentiment ou est-ce qu'au
contraire est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que les passions au sens large
sont restés en dehors des murs de la
cour d'assises spéciale c'était en effet
la crainte qu'on avait tous au démarrage
de ce procès évidemment on se rappelle
tous de ce qu'on faisait le 13 novembre
c'est un c'est une attaque historique
c'est un procès historique à la hauteur
des attaques et en fait j'ai un bilan
plutôt positif à l'issue de ces débats
moi j'ai le sentiment que les juges ont
réussi à faire la part des choses il
faut savoir aussi que c'est des
magistrats professionnels c'est la
particularité de ce procès normalement
aux assises on a un juré populaire est
lassé des professionnels qui connaissent
le métier qui connaissent le droit qui
ne sont pas en principe impressionné par
par l'émotion évidemment palpable
évidemment existante ce n'est pas le
sujet et donc je prends je pense que
finalement on est parvenu à arriver à
une certaine mesure est une espèce de
nuances et je dois dire que les
réquisitions en ce qui concerne mohamed
amri et notre client ont été ces mesures
et il me semble même si vous avez plaidé
l'acquittement le corps de l'avocat doit
être celui d'une certaine droiture
lorsqu'il plaide je crois que c'est vous
qui l'avez dit il ya quelques mois dans
les colonnes du figaro il me semble la
pianiste que vous êtes vous êtes tenus
droite il hier devant la cour d'assises
spéciale au sens propre comme au sens
figuré
j'ai essayé dit oui et puis
à ma
charge presque c'était facile parce que
je parlais beaucoup de droits
ma plaidoirie était très technique il
s'agissait de démonter l'élément
intentionnel de
de la qualification c'est à dire dire
que matériellement mohamed amri avait en
effet commis ce qu'on lui reproche c'est
à dire des transports aller chercher à
les récupérer le règlement absolument
simplement intentions l'intentionnalité
n'était pas la sienne qu' il ne l'a pas
fait en connaissance de cause en sachant
qu' il allait être utilisé pour la
préparation des attentats d'ailleurs le
parquet a indiqué qu'il avait
probablement été instrumentalisée et
tout le paradoxe est tous les dangers il
me semble c'est d'admettre qu'il a été
instrumentalisée mais pour autant
requérir une condamnation contre lui si
vous défendez est mohamed amri depuis
2015 c'est d'ailleurs l'un des rares
prévenu corrigez moi si je me trompe
dans ce procès à ne pas avoir changé
d'avocat depuis le début de la procédure
c'est parce que vous étiez commise
d'office vous raconter que vous l'avez
vu débouler un jour littéralement vous
étiez deux gardes lui cagoulés entouré
de gendarmes eux aussi cagoules et au
nom de quoi nega railleries n'avez vous
pas hésité à prendre sa défense
vous savez en fait on se pose pas
vraiment cette question c'est à dire que
vous voyez tout à coup et débarqué
devant vous un homme effectivement
c'était la logistique était très
impressionnante alors on n'était pas
tout à fait ce n'est pas en 2015 et en
2016 mohamed amri a d'abord été
interpellé en belgique au lendemain des
attentats donc le 14 novembre 2015 et si
à la suite son déferrement devant le
juge français qui devront qu'il a été
mise en examen qu'il a fallu prendre un
avocat et c'est là que j'ai je suis
intervenu et en effet la logistique
était très impressionnante hier que j'ai
vu une personne qui étaient cagoulés
avec une quinzaine de d'escort autour
d'eux autour d'elle autour de cette
personne et vous savez de l'art vous
avez une espèce d'élan presque
fraternelle en fait vous ne pensez pas à
ce qu'il a fait vous pensez à l'homme
qu'il est et vous vous dites voilà il
faut faye a aucune raison qui vous
empêcherait de d'être à ses côtés au
moment où il est le plus isolé vous
l'avez vu le changer au cours de ces
sept dernières années si oui comment
complètement c'est assez incroyable
moi mesdames c'est quelqu'un qui est
très très assez timide à ses réserves et
qui a une difficulté aussi d'expression
il est pas bon à l'oral je pense qu'il
n'a pas confiance dans son dans son
raisonnement dans son vocabulaire donc
en fait quand il s'exprime il a du mal
on le sent et je dois dire qu'il ya eu
une première évolution aussi ces
dernières années partir du moment où il
s'est senti soutenu mais la plus grande
évolution et c'est en cela aussi que je
suis assez satisfaite de ce procès ça a
été ces neuf derniers mois dire que moi
madame brille aujourd'hui à l'issue de
ce procès n'est plus celui qui l'a été
celui qu'il était il ya neuf mois et je
pense que c'est aussi le fait enfin on
peut remercier le fait d'être ce qu'il
explique c'est d'être revenu au contact
des hommes il a été en détention
provisoire pendant six ans ces derniers
mois à l'isolément c'est quand même très
compliqué visuellement sierre que vous
vous ne voyez absolument personne
lorsque vous vous sortez pour faire
votre promenade vous êtes tout seul
alors et on peut pas s'en réjouir c'est
pas possible cirque on ne peut pas
admettre dans une société civilisée
dans une société dans laquelle on est
fier d'être d'exister on ne peut pas se
satisfaire qu'un homme quoi qu'il ait
fait soit à l'isolément la rupture avec
l'autre c'est la porte ouverte à la
faune ici c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
violents vous parlez de fierté est ce
que vous diriez que ces neuf mois de
procès ont fait honneur à la justice
française j'ai envie d'attendre le
délibéré pour vous répondre mais oui oui
moi je trouve ça beau quand
quand en dépit du pire en dépit du chaos
en dépit de ce qu'on peut reprocher et à
juste titre la question n'est pas de
remettre en question l'atrocité de ces
crimes la question c'est en dépit de ce
chaos réussissent réussir à faire
quelque chose c'est à dire vous avez en
filigrane la radicalité dans toute son
atrocité la violence dans à son plus
haut degré et en dépit de ça il faut
réinjecter de la mesure c'est cette
espèce de contraste qui est qui à la
fois difficile à tenir et en même temps
magnifique et ça je trouve que c'est
sage tant que c'est une réussite vous
savez il ya des moments incroyables où
il y avait une espèce de
d'union ou certaines victimes sans les
voir certains des accusés qui étaient
libres pour leur témoigner de leur
soutien enfin on a eu une espèce de les
frontières qui sont habituelles dans un
processus judiciaire
ont été complètement brouillé un moment
donné et on ne pouvait que s'en réjouir
et qu'attribue de ce tableau comment
peut-on défendre l'indéfendable c'est
une question qui est posée non pas
depuis quelques mois mais presque
j'allais dire depuis que le métier
existe en avocat une avocate en
l'occurrence qu'est ce que la dimension
terroriste de la sphère changement à la
question
je voudrais vous dire que ça ne change
rien en fait au départ c'était peut-être
une posture et là je me rends compte que
ça ne change vraiment rien c'est à dire
que il faut toujours avoir en tête que
quand on est avocat on ne défend pas
l'acte reproché aux clients c'est à dire
quand vous avez un client qui à qui on
reproche des faits de viol des faits de
pédophilie c'est-à-dire on peut se
l'accordé le plus haut degré de
l'horreur on ne défend ni la pédophilie
nie le viol on défend un homme à qui il
est reproché des actes atroces et que ce
soit à juste titre dire qu'il les ait
vraiment commis ces actes ou pas il
reste un homme et c'est ça qu'il faut
parvenir à maintenir garder en tête est
ce que ce sera donc les peines sont
attendus le 29 juin prochain est ce que
ce sont vraiment ces peines qui
détermineront si la société française
sort victorieuse d'une certaine façon de
quelque chose comme ça
en ce sens que s que ce procès en ce
qu'il a été ces neuf derniers mois
a pu permettre de mettre en échec un
projet de terroristes même si d'une
certaine façon il a eu lieu c'est pas le
délibéré qui qui nous prouve que nous
avons triomphé c'est le
l'établissement la constitution de ce
procès c'est d'avoir
c'est d'avoir joué les règles du jeu
judiciaire c'est ça qui est important en
fait toujours c'est à dire maintenir le
cap tout à l'heure vous me demandiez si
j'étais restée droite c'est ça qui est
important c'est à dire lorsque tout va
mal maintenir coûte que coûte quoi qu'il
en soit maintenir la la permanence des
règles de droit quoi qu'on ait fait nous
on répond de manière constante
permanente part par l'application la
plus exacte et la plus précise du droit
et c'est précisément contre ça va pas
qu'il faut tout ferrand 5 il faut faire
le maximum pour faire en sorte que ces
règles sont appliquées dans leur plume
dans leur plus grande pureté en ce sens
à ce qu'il faudrait juger en france les
djihadistes france est aujourd'hui
détenue en irak ont mentionné oui moi je
pense qu'il faut pas avoir peur de sa
justice
c'est presque un aveu de faiblesse on a
les outils on a la culture on n'a pas
peur c'est comme ça qu'il faut répondre
il faut rapatrier les enfants il faut il
faut défendre il faut défendre est ici
ceux qui viennent de chez nous voilà
votre confrère avec lequel vous
connaissant des mohamed amri a dit à
emmanuel carrère qui vous consacre un
portrait à tous les deux dans l'obs être
le témoin de cette décennie de
djihadisme vous êtes vous de cette
génération comme moi qui avons été
touchés de plein fouet et bien sûr par
ce mois de novembre 2015 les attentats
qui ont précédé ceux qui ont suivi en
quoi ça a changé l'avocate que vous êtes
je pense que ça m'a donné encore plus
envie de me rapprocher des règles et
d'être rigoureuse et inflexible sur les
règles c'est presque paradoxal mais à la
radicalité de ces gens là il faut
opposer une radicalité dans
l'inflexibilité de l'application des
règles
on a dit la cour d'assises spéciale de
paris se prononcera donc sur ce verdict
j'espère utiliser le bon mot le 29 juin
prochain il y a encore pendant quelques
jours les plaidoiries de la défense
ensuite on donnera la parole aux accusés
c'est un site que qu'est la loi ici en
france qu attendez vous que dix mois
mais d'abord il faut qu' il faut que je
lui demande ces derniers temps je me
suis vraiment concentré sur sur la
plaidoirie donc j'ai un peu délaissé
le plus important c'est que ça vienne de
lui et d'ailleurs ça a toujours été ma
relation avec lui c'est à dire que je ne
vais jamais imposé ce qu'il devait dire
il a toujours des marais des intentions
de mots et ensuite moi j'étais là pour
les reformuler si jamais
il avait du mal à le faire donc
je pense qu'il aura 1 1
un témoignage une attention
pour les parties civiles et puis il
faudrait qu'il dise ce qu'il a envie de
dire tout en étant cours et synthétique
alors c'est
il faut être très précis sur ce terme là
parce que ils regrettent leur tour
l'infraction est caractérisée c'est à
dire qu'il a effectivement ramener salle
abdeslam au moment où il le prend dans
la voiture en apprenant qu'il venait de
participer aux attentes a donc tout le
retour s'est fait avec la connaissance
la conscience qu'il ramenait quelqu'un
qui était ce qu'on appelle un criminel
en tout cas dans la mesure où ils là il
se dit avoir participé aux attentats
avoir une implication de certaines
applications aux attentats mais pour ce
qui précède donc voilà pour ça il peut
regretter en revanche pour ce qu'il
précède il l'admet les actes dans leur
matérialité mais pas dans leur reer
avoir trace yona liés à la location
notamment d' absolument absolument donc
donc pour ça et je pense pas qu'ils le
regrettent au sens au sens d'une
caractérisation parfaite de la
qualification donc c'est c'est assez
subtil il le regrette une partie de ce
qu'on lui reproche mais il ne peut pas
regretter le reste puisqu'il ne pense
pas il le conteste avoir commis ces
actes en connaissance de cause merci
pour la précision du propos merci
beaucoup d'égards aéré d'être venu ce
matin sur le plateau de paris dira était
donc ce procès qui se poursuit jusqu'à
la fin de la semaine il me semble ou
même encore un peu un peu après la suite
des plaidoiries de la défense le dernier
a plaidé sera seront les défenseurs de
salah abdeslam verdict donc attendu le
29 juin et la fin et après il y aura
éventuellement un appel merci encore
très bonne journée